very busy Dan a busy week for you Prime
Minister appreciate your time here today
and just wanted to say to you of course
though that you're not the only party
leader in Manchester certainly you
weren't yesterday were you surprised
that Jeremy Corbyn turned up apparently
that's a bit of a a break and protocol
well I mean it's a free country he can
go where he likes and say well say what
he likes and so I'm not gonna restrict
his movements I think what's more
worrying is what he's saying which is
that he wants to put up taxes which
would wreak economic security he wants
to give up nuclear weapons which would
wreck our national security so it's not
a very edifying message but back here at
the conservative conference we're
delivering the security stability and
opportunity that our country needs what
about the other things he's saying about
austerity and tax credits and the eight
thousand plus people who are saying it
with him do you dismiss all they have to
say on that front not at all look of
course people have a right to protest
but the argument I would make is look if
you ignore a budget deficit if you go on
borrowing year after year you end up not
helping the poorest in your country but
hurting the poorest in your country I
mean look at countries that have lost
control of their finances take a country
like Greece it actually slashed slashed
its health budget by 14% now because
we've taken the long term and difficult
decisions to get our finances back
towards balance we've actually been able
to put 10 billion pounds extra into our
NHS so taking these difficult decisions
and realizing that living within your
means what I would call it rather than
austerity living with your means is the
right thing to do means you can help
working people but people on tax credits
that's not about living within your
means I know you say eight or 10 people
would be better off but two out of ten
are going to be a lot worse off and I
think it's just maybe the whole tone of
things maybe the way Jeremy hunts come
out and talked about and yesterday and
how did he put it he said dignity is not
just about how much money you've got if
you're earning it yourself you're
independent and that's the first step
towards self-respect hardly tell out of
two the steel workers in red car who
didn't even get a mention in George
Osborne's speech yesterday
well look to the steelworkers in red car
I I would say we'll do everything we can
to help you we've already put 80 million
pounds on the table to try and help
regenerate the area to help give people
training to help those who want to start
out on their own if we look across the
Northeast we are seeing regeneration a
whole new industry trained manufacturing
has just opened with the Hitachi plant
at Newton a cliff you've got car
manufacturing in the Northeast going
well but there's more we need to do
that's what we've got to do is as the
Chancellor was talking about yesterday
genuinely rebalance our economy we've
seen it another two million people in
work since I became Prime Minister but
there's more to be done Len McCluskey
says we you see you say you see 2
million more and work the tax credit
cuts he says it's a disgraceful insult
to three million people claiming them
could you just explain to people Prime
Minister why you feel you have to cut
that tax credit well what we're doing is
moving towards an economy where instead
of low pay high welfare and high taxes
we have higher pay lower taxes and lower
welfare so next year the lowest paid
people in our country those on minimum
wage because of the national living wage
they will get a 20 pound a week pay rise
and by the end of this Parliament the
national living wage will be 9 pounds an
hour added to that next year you'll be
able to earn eleven thousand pounds
before you pay any income tax at all now
I accept we are combining those two
measures with a reduction in welfare not
least because we need to get on top of
our national finances get our budget
deficit down and have a welfare and
public services in our country that we
can afford for the long term see to me
that sounds like and to make an omelet
you've got to crack a few eggs is that
just unfortunate you think in the long
term those people will be better off but
in the short term there are going to be
casualties and quite a lot of them but
if we take for instance say a family
with children where there's one member
of the family on minimum wages the
effect of our changes to the national
living wage - taxes - welfare will mean
that that family is 2,400 pounds
better off now except that different
families will be affected differently
but the concept and the introduction of
this higher wage economy combined with
lower taxes and reduced welfare I think
is fair for all I think will deliver a
stronger economy I think will actually
tackle some of the causes of poverty
where we should be helping people to get
jobs earn decent money through those
jobs and pay less in taxes I think that
we'll have the good effect and you would
dismiss that that shows a contempt for
people on low pay because that's the
accusation that has been leveled towards
Jeremy Hunt well look the first thing
what I'd say is the best way to help
people on low pay is to put up their pay
and cut their taxes I think the old
system where what we did was we gave we
took away money in people from people in
taxes gave it back to them in tax
credits created and expensive and
unworkable merry-go-round whereas what
we have now is you earn more you pay
less in tax and I think that makes for a
a fairer and a more efficient economy as
for what Jeremy Hunt said I think he is
being widely miss quoted and that's why
he himself went out again and said let
me be clear what we're talking about is
making sure Britain is one of the
success stories in our world and making
sure that we help people to get work and
provide for themselves and their
families but he did say we should work
like the Chinese and and the Americans
prepared to work hard in the way that
the Americans and the Chinese are
prepared to work hard which sort of
implies that we don't at the minute as I
say he came out afterwards and made
clear Britain British people do work
very hard well one of the hardest
working nations on earth if you look at
the percentage of our people that are in
work it's at an all-time high in our
history we've got more women in work
than at any time in our history and
Jeremy Hunt has been absolutely clear
about that at Teresa May she says mass
immigration forcing thousands of British
people out of jobs and make it
impossible to build a cohesive Society
do you agree yes I agree with what
Teresa May saying which is that look we
are an open economy we benefit from
people coming to our country we should
be proud of the
fact that we built one of the most
successful multi-ethnic multiracial
societies anywhere on earth and that's a
source of great pride to us as as
Britons but immigration works best if
it's controlled immigration so we can
make sure that school places and
hospital beds and communities can
actually cope with a level of migration
and I think in recent years the levels
have been too high which is why we're
committed to bring them down
part of the problem has been that we've
created more jobs than the rest of the
European Union put together and I would
say you know the flip side of
immigration control is we need to make
sure that we are providing the education
and the training and the apprenticeship
and the skills for our own people to do
the jobs that our economy is creating
which links to another issue of today
which is this one of truancy you know
we've got now increasingly in some of
the poorest parts of our country schools
that are turning out great results but
we need to make sure our children are
getting to those schools and that's why
I'm announcing today that we're your
children persistently truant and you're
fined as is the current system if those
fines aren't paid they should come out
of your child benefit because as parents
we've all got a duty to get our children
into school because if they don't go to
school they'll get worse results their
have worst job prospects that wrecked
their life chances and that's not the
sort of society we should be building
very fair point and to use your own
phrase that links to another job which
is your own job and there now you stride
out of your home that's a great link yes
I'm learning from the master here and
basically I saw you striding out of your
hotel today you head off to conference
there you're a man who's got an appetite
for this job you have things to do you
you you've got a lot of unfinished
business and as well which leads me to
the point you've got them all you know
in this beauty contest of Jeremy Hunt
and Niki Morgan and Boris Johnson and
razor May are you gonna break their
hearts in a few years time because maybe
you know when you definitely finally
utterly are you going to call it a day
or could you be tempted no I I won't be
tempted look I'm as far as I can see it
I am half way through this job I've got
an immense passion for it I leap out of
bed every day feeling what an honor it
is to serve this great country of ours
but there's so much for us to do we've
got a stronger economy
let's finish that work let's add to that
a more secure country and let's add to
that a country where we build genuine
social mobility so people can go from
the bottom to the very top I've got a
huge passion for this job
I've also got a talented team behind me
and after I've done the the two terms
the ten years I'm sure there'll be many
talented people who put their their name
forward and I'm frankly I'm proud of
them proud of the fact that you know
they're increasingly being noticed for
being a talented bunch okay and I've had
a tenner who should have put it on PM
I'm not really a betting man well I
never really luckily I never inherited
to have it so very good got me at 33 to
1 so you never know you know so you
never know you not saying no never say
never no I am saying no let me be clear
I was not saying put a bet on me I will
not be there okay thanks for your time
today have a good rest of conference
Prime Minister thank you very much
indeed
33 to 1 your money's wasted he's saying
he's saying thank you